suite à cette escroquerie sociale à
découvert elle a décidé par haute parce
que pour elle estimé qu'elle allait
ramener des problèmes à la maison elle a
décidé de mettre fin à ses jours donc en
garde evry courcouronnes dans l'essonne
en se positionnant sur la voie ferrée en
attendant que voilà que notre impasse
donc ce jour déjà ce drame nous a donc
nous sommes toujours choquée traumatisée
par cette flamme mais ce qui nous a
aussi choqué c'est qu'un individu qui
étaient présents ce jour là la
photographier à travailler donc la photo
jouera en mettant un emoticon un
commentaire pour le diffuser son réseau
social napster chape donc déjà notre
douleur à ses immenses n'a fait que
basser voilà c'est cet élément 7 et
actes de la photographier la vékat
croître de notre douleur donc notre
famille a décidé de poursuivre cet
individu en justice pour déjà et d'une
voilà je ne dirais pas l'obtenir mais
qu'ils aient conscience de ce geste mais
surtout alerter l'opinion publique que
cette banalisation donc de filmer
photographier
voilà des personnes en souffrance
voilà qui valait au ballast lancé quand
même une alerte en disant qu'il faut
stopper ça